Actually, I remember I was a little stream yesterday.
I had a person coming and being like, why do you guys hate America?
We don't hit American heritage. How absurd America.
Talk about Americans is like the way I liked, like to on my cousins.
You know what I mean? It's it's,
it's like the distant cousin that I just like to talk about.
We don't hate on America. We just like making fun of America.
There's a big difference.
You know, Europe's boring. There's nothing weird about it. America is weird.
Yeah, no, I, it comes from a place of love. You know what I mean? This,
this is how us Brits show like, well, you know, we, we talked to our like mates.
Yeah. That's how I see it.
Like in it, all your teeth are. What? Go and drink some tea. Like, wait,
why are you making fun of America?
Canton, you call consummate. That's how it works.
True. True. Would you ever live in America?
I'm going to ask this before on the podcast.
I think you've asked me on the podcast.
I think I've asked you post problem what your answer was.
That's why I'm asking you.
I mean like I've given it.
Well, you can see what your dating. Oh yeah. You can do both. Yeah.
We hate Americans. We hate America.
We hate Americans so much so that our significant others.
Are Americans.
The way Sydney talks to me about food sometimes with like a nostalgia.
I'm like disgusting. Gosh.
Sit at living in America for maybe like a year just to like give it a go.
Silent. I would go there to visit, you know, like I don't.
Visiting. Like I love visiting America, but I don't, I don't like, I don't know.
Just difference in personality, at least with me.
And like way of living is like, it's very different to what I'm used to.
Open everyone is [inaudible] open everyone. Yeah.
I feel like the biggest thing I would have to get to is like,
I like feeling safe. Yeah.
The only thing stopping me from living in America is the fact that even during
the day, I don't feel safe. Yeah. Like it's, it's so weird for me.
Whether the way you can be in some of the most famous places in the world in
America, and you just can't walk anywhere. I like, I like walking to places,
you know what I mean?
I feel like I have to recalibrate my brain in order to go, like in,
in order to travel to places in America.
Because I forget that you have to just drive everywhere and just walking.
Isn't normalized because you could, you know, it's, it's just not safe.
Even when you're in like the middle of LA, right? Like, you'd be like, Oh,
you know, I'll just like go to the Starbucks. That's just around the corner.
You know? It's like just going to the next town in an RPG.
And yet on the street corner,
there's a level 100 crackers standing there being like, looking at a composite.
When I was in San Francisco, man,
I felt like I was walking back to my hotel at 2:00 AM.
Felt like a cyberpunk mission, dude.
The music was playing in my ears like that. You said you walked back at 2:00 AM,
like already scares me. Yeah.
Okay. I legit have never been scheduled walking somewhere.
I was in right in the middle of like the financial district in San Francisco.
I was like. I think I've mentioned it before on a podcast as well. But yeah,
that was scary. I'm scared. I'm scared thinking about it.
That's the only thing that's stopping.
Me from living in America.
Everyone I know from San Francisco has had the car broken into.
I've heard so many weird stories about like some of the stories that Malin says,
cause Malin is on Sanford is from San Fran where it's one of it's like it, it,
so counter-intuitive for me where this is the place where it's got like one of
like the highest cost of living.
Like a million dollars a year, like a millionaire.
Is considered like poor there. You know what I mean? That's, that's kind of,
that's kind of the place we're talking about yet.
It's a place where the cost of living is so high yet.
It seems like you still need to worry about some of the stuff where I feel like
if I'm earning a million dollars, I wouldn't need to worry about it. Like if I,
why would I need to worry?
Like why would I need to pay this much and worry about living in a neighborhood
where my car could get broken into? Yeah.
It feels like everyone who I've met from San Fran has had something stolen.
They talk about things. They talk about that as if they got like a parking like,
Oh, got it again. Oh, well,
when Malin was talking about how she has to have like one headphone in,
just in case there's someone behind her to like take her purse or something.
I'm like, what the, what the? Like, why would you,
how do you feel safe living in the city like that? Or a country like that?
For that matter.
I convinced the cyber truck's being made as purely second with Stan criminals in
San Francisco are breaking in.
Everyone's going to be in like like Ahmed trucks in San Francisco,
but they'll still find a way to break into it. Yeah.
Right. But that's the thing. The only places I feel safe in America,
I like the super tourist heavy places. Right? Yeah.
So like the peers in San Francisco or like, you know, Vegas strip, right.
UK, somewhere in the middle.
I think like you can't really like leave your laptop on the dashboard. Really?
No.
I would argue though, this is like, other than Japan is not a lot of countries.
No, but like in the UK I'd I'd leave like my, my headphones on the chair.
I don't really mind risking that. I'm like, whatever. No,
I wouldn't even do that. Depends. Are you all in London? No. Other like Wales.
Yeah. It's whatever. Well, yeah, because that's countryside, right?
What are they going to do? Run away with the sheep.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. I don't know. I mean it's yeah. I don't know. It's weird.
I really want to,
I've always said this I've always wanted to live in America for a year.
I would like to live in America for like trying it out. Yeah.
I think if I moved from Japan, I think I would like to try and get.
I'm I'm I'm still like,
because me and Cindy want to move to America for a bit because like her family's
there and you know, she wants to be close to her family for a while.
It's just finding the perfect place that I would actually want to live in.
Cause I don't,
I don't know where I could see myself settling down in America makers like,
you know, for YouTube is it's like the number one spot is always LA, but.
Living in LA. Sorry for from LA. No,
it's not about it's about LA. YouTube is man it's Oh yeah.
She was a different beast, man. They, they are a different breed.
Like every,
every like there's I feel like there was literally just two scenes on YouTube,
YouTube and Lau chili. Like it's totally different. Like I, I like,
and you know, when someone's living in LA, I swear. Cause when you talk to them,
you're like, bro, you're just like,
in another reality you play by different rules. I'm brainwashed.
But I get it. Cause like when you're there, like.
You feel it,
you feel like you're in a different place when you're in LA and you feel like
everything you do somehow has a bigger weight to it.
I think that's what they think.
It's like brand Mike.
We were talking about cloud chasing before LA Croix.
The center of clout chasing. I feel like everyone's out to get some clout. Yeah.
I feel dirty when I'm there. I'm talking to people. I'm just like, dude,
I'm just, I'm just like, I'm just like trying to get just a style box for her.
Like why, why are we talking about how many subs you have? Like, I don't care.
I really like that donkey video where he like.
Did a commentary over the hundred hundred feeds one.
I learned just like all the house thieves.
New sports organization made by nade shot. He used to be a YouTuber. Yeah.
But yeah, he, he started one, right? So he has his own little,
you want to go tell the rest of it?
Yeah. So he, he basically commentates over like this house tour.
And it's it? It is like when, when, when you would,
the way donkey commentates, it, it, it,
it is basically like you're going into a different world because what was like
the room, like the Tortino's training room or something.
I'm just like, it sounds like, uh,
like you say it out of context and this sounds like a dystopia.
I have a sponsor in the building. So when you mentioned I'm in this room,
you have to say like I'm in the monster energy gaming room.
I won that for trash tastes.
This is Al Del taco's toilet. I'm in the
[inaudible] sponsor Ralphie room. Yes. Yes.